[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de cette vie de culture
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mardi
est 7 mai le château de versailles vu
par différents architectes avec sa
nouvelle exposition le palais ressemble
rassemble 120 dessins et planches
effectueront deux projets réels utopique
une présentation dans le cadre de la
biennale d'architecturé de paysage de la
région ile de france
direction le pays imaginaire à la ferme
de bel ébat la jeune troupe de la
structure fait revivre l'histoire
mythique de ce personnage qui refuse de
grandir
pascal anthony signe la mise en scène de
cette création
trois concerts pour un quart de siècle
ce week-end le groupe keur accord fête
ses 25 ans on trouve notamment une
chanson française le château de
versailles un chantier permanent de
nombreux projets ont été pensées du
règne de louis xiv à l' empire pour la
première fois l'établissement présente
ses réflexions plus ou moins ambitieuse
au public l'exposition est organisée
dans le cadre de la première biennale
d'architecturé du paysage ile de france
qui a débuté le 4 mai dernier dans la
cité royale sujet réalisé avec aurélie
rose et calypso vanille et c'est un
petit bout d'un grand projet l'ale
gabriel est construite en 10 771 pensé
par ange jacques gabriel aussi créateur
de l'opéra royal
l'architecte propose pendant 25 ans des
projets au roi mais son projet était
beaucoup plus ambitieux il s'agissait de
reconstruire totalement le coeur du
château de versailles
supprimer tout ce qui pouvait rappeler
le premier château le château briques et
pierres de louis xiv pour donner une
harmonie à la façade un chantier stoppé
par la mort de louis 15 en 1774 comme ce
grand projet l'exposition architecture
rêver révèle les idées qu'ils n'ont
jamais été réalisé le château a servi de
lieu d'inspiration du xviie jusqu'à l'
empire
le dessin architecture peut être du très
beau dessin c'est aussi l'un des
objectifs de l'exposition c'est de
montrer finalement ces dessins qui sont
souvent peu connus qui sont exploitées
par les historiens pour leurs intérêts
on va dire historique intellectuelle
mais qui ne sont pas montrés finalement
pour eux mêmes pour leurs qualités
esthétiques
près de 120 dessins sont rassemblés des
dessins d'architecturé des plans des
projets parfois ambitieux comme cette
chute au pied détiennent oui vous les
architectes du xviiie siècle
son projet est véritablement d'avancé
considérablement la façade est de
supprimer tout ce qui
visuellement bloc cette vue sur la
façade
il élargit considérablement l'avant
cours
il supprime les ailes des ministres l'un
des projets les plus grandioses estimé
alors à près de 14 millions de livres
des utopies et des réalités qui donne un
autre regard sur le palais
plus de deux mois de réflexion sur
l'architecturé le paysage du 4 mai au 13
juillet c'est donc la ville de
versailles qui accueille cette première
benne biennale de la région ile de
france six grandes expositions 12 grands
débats des rencontres et des événements
sont organisés et je vous propose
d'écouter valérie pécresse la présidente
de la région
elle était au micro de manon varaldo je
voulais qu'on donne à voir à tous les
franciliens ce que le grand paris allait
être en 2030
alors nous avons lancé cette biennale il
était tout à fait naturel que je confie
ce projet à françois de mazières parce
que françois de mazières était à
l'origine du projet du grand paris à 10
ans en tant que président de la cité de
l'architecturé il m'a proposé
l'écrin de la ville de versailles pour
pour installer cette biennale dans
l'école architecture dans l'école du
paysage au potager du roy une ombre une
fait est un pays imaginaire vous aurez
bien sûr reconnu peter pan ce garçon qui
refuse de grandir inspiré pascal anthony
il signe la mise en scène d'une création
à découvrir ces 10 et 11 mai bonjour
vous êtes accompagné de deux comédiens
les ânes france us et mathis de news est
respectivement wendy et peter pan
bonjour à tous les joueurs parce qu'un
donnait déjà pourquoi peter pan alors
pour situer un peu les choses le
la ferme de bel ébat le théâtre de
guyancourt organise depuis maintenant
huit ans un principe assez
extraordinaire c'est une invention assez
ingénieuse qui était l'initiative de
johan lavabre son directeur d'avoir mis
en place un atelier d'adolescents qui
travaillent toute l'année et arrive à la
fin de l'année comme tous les ateliers
de france et de navarre
il ya un spectacle là les conditions
sont un petit peu plus extraordinaire
puisque les les adolescents sont
mobilisés sur une durée de deux semaines
de résidence dans un théâtre qui est en
fonctionnement et cela aboutit donc un
spectacle dans des conditions
professionnelles
d'autant plus que sur chaque projet le
l'équipe est constituée aussi de
comédiens professionnels donc il ya ce
mélange fabuleux qui s'opère cette année
donc c'est une adaptation peter pan qui
a été écrite il ya quelques années par
un auteur gallois
au tour donc au tour de peter pan dans
une version un peu plus comment
dirais-je qui rejoint un petit peu
l'origine de la pièce qui date du début
du siècle dont qui offre à cette
histoire un puits sans fond qui n'est
pas forcément celui que le public peut
connaître à travers
voilà on est dans une dans une
confrontation donc de ce personnage
peter pan avec le capitaine crochet un
peu plus du en disons que que le walt
disney qu'on connaît une adaptation
théâtrale conséquente avec beaucoup de
personnages et un propos assez
intéressant voilà d'un peter pan qui
quelque part combat un petit peu le
monde réel refuse aussi le dit dans la
pièce refuse le peut-être le le monde
capitaliste voilà dans dents
à la fin de la pièce d'ailleurs il
renonce à ce monde réel puisqu'il a la
possibilité d'y rentrer par
l'intermédiaire du personnage de wendy
voilà justement ce à peter pan il est
avec nous ce soir mathis vous jouez donc
le rôle principal comment est ce que
vous l'avez appréhender le travail un
peter pan qu'on a tous connu dans notre
enfance
oui ben déjà en fait dans cette
adaptation là c'est plutôt peter pan et
wendy parce que wendy est très
importante on a appelé des deux rôles
principaux si ce n'est que wendy à
presque 1 un plus grand rôle
et puis parfois on fait finalement la
compagne presque dans dans pour qu'elle
grandisse il y lit la faire revenir un
petit peu en arrière puisque wendy vient
de perdre sa mère et donc c'est un petit
peu un personnage presque complètement
magique
un enfant qui ne veut pas grandir un peu
la face de wendy qui voudraient rester
en enfance mais elle a des obligations
qui l'obligé à grandir donc pour ça on
j'ai pris par exemple un accent anglais
pour un peu changé complètement ma
manière d'être et à travers l'accent
c'était assez efficace puis on annonce
attaque censée vous qu'il l'avait
proposé ça a été la mise en scène
comment ça s'est passé cet échange s'est
on a eu l'année pour faire des
tentatives comme ça en improvisation et
puis après c'est un échange qui se fait
il suffit d'une petite étincelle qu'on
transforme en feu en idées donc voilà
c'est à force de faire des essais
notamment en improvisation
que les choses se construisent peu à peu
effectivement ça a été le cas ça donne à
ce personnage info en tout cas au rôle
de l'interprète matisse une singularité
dans sa manière de penser d'ailleurs il
hâtives même quoi pour aborder ce rôle
un peu qui est un peu étrange finalement
parce que c'est un personnage quand même
keita fait assez égoïste assez assez dur
voilà les ânes j'allais dire oui on
parlait des ateliers justement de
création c'est ce qui vous a plu dans
cette aventure c'était pas pour
professionnels webb a bien sûr des
rapports professionnels parce que déjà
là à la fin on a deux semaines donc de
stage avec à la ferme de bel ébat et que
des professionnels des comédiens qui
jouent avec nous des régisseurs et même
durant toute l'année donc on faisait d
une fois par semaine on se rejoint des
improvisations donc j'avais même des
fois aussi les comédiens qui venait
aussi et voilà comment on laissait pas
passer notre imagination à travers
travers sa de faire jouer des enfants
ça demande un investissement particulier
des défis aussi enfants des adolescents
oui parce qu'on a on a un peu deux âges
on a des enfants des enfants qui ont
autour de 10 12 ans et puis eux qui sont
un peu plus âgés
donc nous oui non enfin oui parce que
c'est toujours très difficile de monter
une pièce là qui va durer à peu près une
heure une heure car enfin 1h45
donc c'est une grosse machine donc ça
demande une concentration une attention
c'est assez miraculeux finalement tout
ce qui se passe à la ferme de bel ébat
de durant les mois j'en ai déjà fait un
spectacle dans ce contexte il ya chaque
fois que j'ai vu des autres spectacles
c'était assez miraculeux comme ça en un
an de produire autant de qualités à
l'arrivée voilà puisque simone nôtre
comment dire notre métier que d'un
d'accompagner les jeunes là nous sommes
une équipe conséquente il ya un
accompagnement chorégraphique à une
création lumière il ya une quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de la scénographie il ya
isabelle olivier pour la musique il ya
un conseiller au cirque aussi hein parce
qu'il ya un peu de manipulation
circassienne on peut leur apporter
vraiment le monde du spectacle en une
création
quelque part oui en tout cas c'est ce
format réduit
c'est tout cet apport quoi merci
beaucoup on est un peu pris par le temps
mais pour découvrir ce peter pan dont
vous avez donné quelques échos au rendez
vous les 10 et 11 mai prochains à la
ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt trois
niveaux entièrement consacré aux jeux et
aux jouets à poissy le musée s'est
refait une beauté pendant trois ans le
11 mai prochain
il reverra ses portes au public pour
emmener petits et grands à travers
l'histoire des jouets 600 d'entre eux
sont rassemblés choisi par les 14000 de
la collection du musée inauguré
aujourd'hui par le ministre de la
culture franck riester
on a repensé scientifiquement déjà le
type de parcours parce qu'avoir ni té de
plus tôt dans une approche thématique du
jouet on avait une salle de poupées une
salle de voitures de train et là l'idée
était d'avancer d'être une base
chronologique du choix donc on a pu
évoquer le jouet depuis l'antiquité
jusqu'à maintenant pour montrer qu'elles
étaient les premières bases de jouets
qui était consul déjà les la rome
antique les propos ont été recueillis
par aurélie rose
un autre sujet maintenant un trésor
malheureusement inexploitées dans le
village de vic depuis 2014 un musée
d'art naïf attend des financements pour
pouvoir être réhabilités et ouvert au
public son maire nous a ouverts nous en
a ouvert les portes et raconter son
histoire en art il n est guère piccino
à
[Musique]
dans le village de vic
situé au centre des yvelines un panneau
nous l'annoncent dès l'entrée ici se
trouve au musée d'art naïf
seulement depuis 2014 il est fermé donc
on a tendance qui était dans le temps
elle accueille aujourd'hui bon bah oui
là c'est encore fermés puisque les
travaux sont pas encore tout à fait fini
donner à la commune il ya 20 ans le
musée sur cet art des autodidactes et
gérée par plusieurs associations
successives
quand la dernière abandonne son
administration revient à la mairie qui
décide de fermer pour mieux réouvrir
après rénovation donc là on rentre dans
la partie qui était ouverte au musée
donc on voit les toiles qui sont encore
qu'il faut encore accrocher une
collection de 800 toile d'or sur les
murs ou dans les emballages à laquelle
s'ajoutent les oeuvres de la défunte
propriétaire des lieux c'est la vue de
la route qui qui est en dessous du musée
avait plus de fafn est elle a fait ça de
sa fenêtre le pari fou d'un
collectionneur et de sa femme qui
rachète ce qui était alors une ferme
pour la transformer en musée
et là on se trouve dans ce qui devait
être l'étape puisqu'on retrouve ici les
auges la vache avec les chaînes qui
étaient là pour attacher les les animaux
et l'os pour pour manger le musée d'art
naïf de vic est inaugurée en 1973 la
collection de max fourni contient 1500
pièces réparties entre le musée de vic
et là elle s'enquiert à paris
aujourd'hui tout repose entre un musée
fermé et le sous sol de la halle cachée
de public
objectif pour le maire rapatrier toutes
ces oeuvres ici et créer en plus une
salle dédiée à son épouse la pianiste
françoise adnet lancé marié avec
monsieur max fournit la laisser tomber
le piano pour
art et repeinte puisque c'est ce qu'a
voulu faire dès le départ un énorme
projet de réhabilitation pour la commune
de 380 habitants passionnés par cette
histoire sont marrés vrai même de la
raconter avec un espace visite dans les
parties privées où a vécu le couple
parce que c'était elle en étant jeune
peut-être oui on trouve un peu ses
traits
j'ai toujours espoir puisque là on on a
à force de chercher des fonds vont on en
a trouvé un peu donc j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir
des mois de septembre à arriver à
continuer à reprendre des travaux il
reprend des travaux intérieurs première
victoire grâce à une aide du département
la réfection de la toiture tout juste
achevé dans la mairie de vic les plans
du futur musée sont prêts le projet a
été réfléchie et imaginé pour accueillir
le plus de visiteurs possible les
planques effet le permis de construire a
été déposé et accepté donc tout tout est
prêt pour démarrer il manque
un peu le financement pour tout faire on
a on va avoir le financement pour
commencer les travaux
mais est ce qu'on pourra aller jusqu'au
bout pour l'instant c'est le point
d'interrogation
un prêt qui s'élève tout de même à près
d'un million et demi d'euros sans
compter l'aménagement le maire garde
espoir de trouver des mécènes pour s'est
pris au jeu et maintenant on aimerait
bien le voir le voir fonctionner c'est
quand même
ah bon sol de bataille de quoi s'occuper
pendant quelques années
avis aux amoureux de l'art naïf musée en
plus d'histoires recherche financement
ainsi que fin connaisseur pour en
organiser les expositions un demi-siècle
célébrer en musique en concert ce week
end le coeur accor fait ses 25 ans à la
merise autres ap trois concerts du 10 au
12 mai et pour en parler avec nous la
présidente et la vice-présidente bonjour
à toutes les dates m'en fous je me
tourne d'abord vers vous et manuel ponte
vous êtes la présidente
alors j'imagine que ces concerts cette
année ont une saveur un peu particulière
bien oui puisqu'en fait notre quart de
siècle d'existence
donc voilà qu'un raccord a démarré en
1994 à dix choristes et on se retrouve
25 ans après à 185 choristes dont 180
près de 180 choristes sur scène
180 choristes eux rassemblés au même
endroit sur la même scène
ça demande beaucoup de travail de
répétition où ce que les beaucoup oui ça
demande du travail individuel par
choristes qui doit arriver en chambre
sans partition on doit savoir tout par
coeur chant à quatre voix donc quatre
pupitres différents et puis des
répétitions de l'investissement
personnel et puis après il
mise en commun en répétition tout au
long de l'année et puis bah après voilà
sur sur scène ou ou là on a on a le
coeur rempli d'adrénaline pour donner
beaucoup au public et puis partager
plein de bons moments isabelle les lost
le répertoire du choeur 60 nation
française uniquement la chanson
francophone contemporaine ça va de
johnny hallyday à vianney ou là pour le
plus jeune valable pour les plus jeunes
et
donc on enchaîne 25 titres dont 5 tick
25 ans vous avez parlé fait un retour
sur ses 25 ans de répertoire sur le
concert de cette année pas pas vraiment
cette année on a quelques chances on
comprend mais on n'est plus dans
l'actualité
en fait pour que j'imagine aussi le
public puisse chanter avec vous si
emmanuel fontaine ya pas que des
chanteurs sur scène c'est un peu la
particularité de coeur accoyer a
quasiment pas de chanteur sur scène on
est tous des amateurs
on est tous épris de plaisir à chanter
aimer mais par contre il n'y a aucun
professionnel on s'entoure de
professionnels pour tout ce qui est son
régime lumière mais on est 180 amateurs
personne est casté personnes et
professionnels mais on a tous cette
envie de chanter partager et le nombre
fait que on s'envole tous quel que soit
notre niveau de chant à la base quoi
donc
et le public répond présent j'ai roulé
on a débuté les réservations il ya deux
mois à peu près on est déjà satisfait de
2 du nombre de spectateurs qui vont
venir profiter de ce spectacle est ce
qui vous entendrez chanter qui vous
écouterez ce soir qu'on aurait envie de
vous rejoindre
il n'y a pas de casting mais est ce qu a
quand même des conditions à respecter
delage une question d'âge une question
de peut-être de motivation de d'être
présent à chaque répétition ah oui ça
demande un grand investissement de
chacun mais pas de pad a pas d'âge enfin
la majorité voilà la majorité mais pas
pas d'âge maximum je crois que notre
notre doyen à 93 ans donc voilà après
chacun fait ce qu'il peut mais c'est
aussi ce qui fait la beauté de notre
coeur puisque puisqu'on est très
éclectique on en donne la possibilité à
chacun de venir donc chanter avec nous
donc ceux qui ont vivienne viennent se
renseigner soit sur notre site ou pas
une répétition à la rentrée on est à
l'auditorium de de l'école de musique de
trappes
merci à toutes les deux heures je le
rappelle vous êtes présidente et
vice-présidente de coeur accord qui fête
cette année donc ses 25 ans en chanson à
la mairie à la merise de trappes du 10
au 12 mai après la musique la danse si
vous êtes amateurs la commanderie de 50
ans nuit fais appel à vous elle
recherche des danseurs pour une
performance 6 juillet prochain à la
création la chorégraphe tatiana julien
et sa compagnie pour participer à
turbulences c'est le nom du spectacle il
ya deux week-ends préparatoire en juin
et en juillet seule condition avoir plus
de 16 ans les informations s'affichent à
l'écran
la chorégraphe et ses danseurs vont
investir et complètement transformé
la commanderie puisque la danse sera
partout on est loin d'un spectacle
classique
les spectateurs seront amenés à mettre
un casque audio ils sont complètement
immergé dans une bande son et ils seront
amenés à déambuler librement dans la
commanderie et au hasard de leurs
promenades
ils vont tomber sur un danseur dans tel
endroit un groupe de danseurs à notre
endroit
[Musique]
une lueur
quelqu'un
présent simple
quelque chose un jeu d'intention
[Musique]
au début de cet agenda avec une
conférence la ville de rome dévoile ses
secrets au scarabée de la verrière dans
le cadre des ateliers d'italiens et
d'histoire de l'art rendez vous le
vendredi 10 mai à 19h au théâtre de 50
ans de livin vous pouvez découvrir des
secrets de fabrication les 11 et 12 mai
c'est la chorégraphe maud le pladec qui
se prête aux confessions un partage
autour de divers ateliers
pour y participer il faut être présent
sur les deux jours d'ateliers et avoir
un billet pour la création de mode le
pladec qui s'appelle concrètes
on dit de lui qu'il est une comète
surdoué du jazz européen emile par les
arrêts sur la scène du prisme avec son
quintet à qui il donne inventivité
féroce et élégante
il était écouté le samedi 11 mai
[Musique]
cinq interprètes une douzaine
d'instruments les fouteurs de joie
reviennent à magny les hameaux pour un
voyage sous les étoiles ceux qui se
définissent comme des idiots seront à
l'estaminet le 11 mai prochain
[Musique]
noam elle blues jazz pop et musique
orientale l'artiste revient avec un
nouvel album paru au printemps elle
revisite les grands musique de
jean-sébastien bach avec des textes
qu'elle a elle-même écrit elle se
produit samedi 11 mai à bercy
regardez
[Musique]
mais penske harris de marne est de même
chan
[Musique]
des enfantillages sur scène toujours
plus d'enfantillages aldebert rassemble
à nouveau parents et enfants dans un
concert à vivre en famille il est de
passage de dimanche 12 mai à 17h à
montigny le bretonneux un avant-goût
l'horizon lointain dynamique sans
barreaux deux frères il s'engage
d'un petit lionceau mais c'est ta chance
le monde se marre doucement
deux chalets
car des super pouvoirs
super pour ims étoiles enthousiaste des
robes qui militent et la bienveillance
des songes qui s'invite et filles
voilées bonheur qui a tant qu'ancienne
un monument vivant c'est quoi qu'on dise
c'est fabriquer des premières fois c'est
quoi la france de la tendresse en pyjama
au théâtre montansier on s'intéresse à
honoré de balzac la scène versaillaise
propose gêné grand des six acteurs
portent tour à tour les épisodes du
célèbre roman à découvrir ce vendredi
mais regardez ce jour et est un jour de
fête mais a connu des crues soudaines et
grâce aussi les antagonistes se préparer
ni l'avenir mais d'autres pièces pour se
rencontrer dans la salle et s'est
surpassée entre tu te complais probable
pour la première fois la pensée et des
paraître avec la supériorité d'un jeune
homme à la peau et on termine avec une
exposition art gravure
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donne sa
deuxième carte blanche à chomsky ne
brisent les l'artiste expose jusqu'au 28
mai prochain c'est la fin de ce site une
culture merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve pour un prochain numéro lundi
prochain
[Musique]